anyway speaking of how we're
hardwired let's get into this conflict
thing because so many people would try
to drag me out who who do you stand with
you know if you go on social media
you're you know you're going to start
seeing on on on Facebooks probably I
stand with and then some flag of whoever
they stand with uh you saw it with the
Russian Ukraine conflict you're seeing
it all over Twitter X now um one side is
trending with Israel the other side is
trending with Palestine and it's
flipping back and forth all day long
it's it's pretty clear to me at this
point that um both sides have done some
shitty things and the point that I want
to get at with this cast is they always
try to suck you in when I say they
there's us and then them they are on the
perimeter they're on the outside they
want to suck you in and get you uh
interested and caring about things that
generally speaking you shouldn't really
care about let me explain
so I dug up this isn't the chart that I
wanted to find but I dug up this chart
here let me share it up on the screen
here sh screen um this is what is this
called animation how Europe no this
isn't the European map 600 years of war
so this is the 600 years of war in piece
here it is so this is global deaths and
conflicts since the year 1400 so to the
point of this map is on the bottom axis
here you've got the years the 1400 all
the way up to the uh recent time 2000s
and on the left axis here you've got the
rate of deaths per 100,000 people okay
you can see the rate of deaths per
100,000 people is pretty much stayed
relatively consistent there's been some
Peaks some valleys um there's been some
Wars that have created more deaths than
others but throughout history one thing
is very very common and this is only in
the last 600 years by the way there's
another video that I want to show you
which I'm just going to kind of play in
the background as I'm talking for frame
reference because there's no audio it's
really just how the European map has
changed we'll get to that in a second
but what you'll notice here on this map
is there's a lot of dots each one of
those dot represents a conflict most of
these aren't labeled um if I go to the
top ones over here where there's a lot
of deaths involved and the conflict
lasted for a long period of time you can
start to see some of the like this is
the 30-year War over here this is the
period of the hundredy Year War over
here uh Peasants War in I can't even
Saxons I think it says there's all these
different Wars all the big any when are
all labeled until you get up to World
War I World War II and it looks like
World War II had the largest number of
casualties in total and we haven't seen
World War uh like that of World War II
since this was a
very this was a very traumatic time for
our grandparents and great-grandparents
uh my granddad I guess grew up in both
those Wars my dad was born uh at the end
of the second world war so this period
of time must have been like just [__]
and like conflict after conflict dealing
with Zone after Zone because I remember
my granddad telling me uh stories you he
Us South Africa jalter Singapore Hong
Kong he was with the Royal Air Force so
they so they moved him around a lot but
all of these
conflicts they've been going on since
the beginning of time you know was a
point that I've been trying to make and
the 1400s are not the beginning of time
this is just the beginning of this
particular map there are data points in
other maps that that go even further
back but the common denominator is
there's just dots everywhere it's it's
just covered in literally dots
everywhere this is not a new phenomenon
this has been going on forever so I mean
the first thing that you got to
understand is this ain't gonna stop no
matter how much they want to suck you
into caring about what's happening over
there it it's not going to stop you
caring about it isn't going to change
much them trying to suck you into the
idea of who's right or wrong or what
side to stand on isn't going to change
anything
let them sus it out I like it's gotten
to the point where when people ask me
you know for my opinion on things like
this and that and the other thing it's
like how about we just stop either
printing money or taking taxpayer money
and sending it over in other places when
we've got a world of issues that are
going on in our own backyards here in
North America I mean we've got people
walking into stores and shoplifting with
zero consequences whatsoever they're
telling employees to deal with it let
them walk out and if they try to stop
them they're going to fire them right
because they've got legal issues tied
around that you got wokeness issues they
want you to care about if you don't use
somebody's correct pronouns they want
you to care about all these things
locally here and many of them don't even
matter by the way it's like like there's
core issues that actually matter but
they're trying to distract you with
issues that don't matter or issues on
the other side of the world or the other
Pond or that continent or this continent
or that part of the Equator or whatever
the keep trying to suck us is what I'm
getting at okay and and it's an
unfortunate scenario it sucks that it's
happening people it is inevitable that
people will die it's it's always been
that way throughout history as you know
we see here with this chart I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out